pipette tips they're basically the
toilet paper in the lab where it's one
and done
toilet paper that's why in this video
we're gonna talk about the best tips
on how to choose your pipette tips
yeah man you just use it once one and
done
that's not like you reuse the pipette
too that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard
literally i think you just need to you
know pipe it down
where are you going
why should you choose your pipette tips
carefully the end goal for every lab is
to create highly accurate and
standardized results for your sample so
this means we want to make sure that
every factor that could affect that is
accounted for including pipette tips and
if we don't use the correct pipette tips
or use something that isn't the best
quality then this could potentially
cause problems like wasting your
precious samples and reagents or even
cause repetitive stress injury that's
why the first thing you should do for
any lab is making sure you choose high
quality pipette tips from a reputable
supplier so how do you know
we're a reputable supplier so how do you
know if it's high quality so a great
pipette tip is made up of quality virgin
polypropylene virgin what that fancy
word means is that it's a medical grade
plastic that can handle a wide range of
applications from corrosive material to
something that's a viscous without
altering the sample you also want to
make sure that there isn't any plastic
or metal additives within your pipette
tips so that it doesn't affect your
results and if you're testing with
sensitive microbiological or pcr testing
you want to make sure that they are
certified to be free of rnas dnas dna
pyrogen pcr inhibitors and atp in other
words you don't want anything in your
pipette tips that could potentially
alter results for example let's say that
you're doing a pcr test for a patient
and you just coincidentally happy to
notice that there are traces of rna left
on the pipette tip for some reason then
what could happen is that these results
could potentially be amplified leading
to a false positive in results at the
end of the day a high quality pipette
tip ensures that your results will be
reliable so you could focus more on your
experiments rather than worrying if
there's you know something wrong with
your lab supplies the second thing to
consider is choosing between universal
or proprietary tips and making sure it
fits snugly you see not all pipette tips
are equal i hate to break it to you but
they aren't that's the reality but what
this means for you is that not every
pipette tip is going to fit into your
pipette this means
this means it should easily attach
itself it can stay in place with no
effort and there should be a strong seal
between your pipette and pipette tips
and the reason why you want to do this
is because if there is a pour seal
between your pipet tip and your pipette
then this could potentially mean that
the drawn-out air will escape which will
affect the amount of liquid in the
pipette tip and that's no bueno so one
thing to consider is that there should
be compatibility charts between your
pipettes and pipette tips to make sure
that it fits another thing to consider
is getting proprietary tips versus
universal tips proprietary tips just
means that you're using the name brand
for your specific pipette and universal
pipette tips are designed to be
compatible with most brands you could
think of toilet paper again or you could
either use charm and ultra strong or you
could use a generic toilet paper brand
they both can get the job done however
simon ultra strong definitely costs more
but you know that they are more reliable
versus a generic toilet paper brand
which will definitely be cheaper and
still do a great job but since there's
no name brand you feel you know a little
skeptical about it until you use it it's
the same exact thing with pipette tips
you see you can't go wrong with
proprietary tips but if you're on a
budget you may want to consider looking
at universal pipette tips and as its
name suggests it's universal so it fits
with most brands due to flexible
technology to ensure there is a great
seal helping to secure the pipette and
pipette tip just like all generic toilet
paper not all universal pipette tips are
the same meaning you also want to make
sure and double check that the brand you
choose if you're doing universal pipette
tips is high quality this means one
making sure it's not inconsistent or two
that cheap material is used for the
build of the pipette tips the next
decision you have to make is choosing if
you want a non-filtered or filter tip in
general you want to choose the
non-filtered pipette tips if you're
handling any non-sensitive application
for your experiment that also won't
contaminate your pipettes and these
pipette tips are you know typically
usually cheaper however if you are
handling any clinical samples viscous
samples or even corrosive samples then
using a filter tip would be your best
choice
let's dive in when you should consider
non-filter tips you see non-filter tips
are great for non-sensitive applications
usually they're used for applications
like agarose gels or even plasmid dna
typically you use them when there isn't
too much concern about it contaminating
your pipettes and affecting your future
samples and these are great because they
are the inexpensive choice that usually
comes in bulk or pre-racked which means
more experiments for you at a lower cost
filter tips on the other hand are used
in cases where you are handling
sensitive materials that may contaminate
your samples ironically most filter tips
also known as a barrier tip doesn't have
a physical barrier like only the
high-end ones and instead slow down the
speed of which the sample comes in so
that it is much harder to accidentally
go into your pipette that's why they are
also a perfect choice to help train new
individuals using a pipette for the
first time this is because the filter
helps prevent over-aspiration so taking
too much sample which could potentially
save your pipette from having to be
clean and repaired which costs money so
if you are running a lab filled with
students or training new lab techs
filtered pipette tips are the way to go
they are also great for handling any low
volume material that is rna dna
solutions infectious samples radio
labeled samples volatile corrosive or
viscous samples strong acids or vases
genetic studies forensics or even
something like radio isotope samples oh
i need water
this is
another thing to consider when using
filtered pipette tips is making sure
that you keep your pipettes clean for
example let's go back to pcr testing and
say you decided to use non-filtered
pipette tips doesn't seem that terrible
right
what could potentially happen is that if
there is any cross-contamination in your
sample then it can be amplified during
the process giving you false positive
results and having inaccurate results
for patients can be really bad so be
sure to choose the right pipette tips
for your specific applications to get
accurate results
fourth thing to consider is using low
retention pipette tips because they just
don't hurt to have just like the name
implies what low retention tips means is
that they retain low levels of liquids
this is because the inner surface of
hydrophobic make
this is because the inner surface is
hydrophobic making it easier to release
the liquid of the pipette tip and making
it harder to stick to the surface
they're becoming more and more popular
because they're considered the more
premium tips as there are no downsides
of the one improved sample delivery and
two using the expensive reagents more
effectively that's why they are great
for pcr cloning or any other protein
analysis applications however you want
to make sure that there is no secondary
process during manufacturing that can
cause these compounds to leach from the
tips such as during silicone coating
what happens is when manufacturers are
producing low retention tips they
typically use either a different
polypropylene blend to their standard
tips or add a silicone coating and it's
because both techniques prevent viscous
or low surface tension liquids from
spreading out and wetting the inner
walls of the tips however the latter has
one major disadvantage a silicone
coating can wash or leach out with your
sample so you should always choose tips
with a polypropylene blend offering
heightened hydrophobic properties to
make sure that liquid repellents can't
contaminate your samples so those are
the main things to consider when
choosing a pipette tip now let's go over
some pipette tips and special cases
where they are nice features to have for
pipette tips but not essential to have
one of them is graduated pipette tips
graduated pipette tips have graduated
marks on the side which helps as a
precaution to make sure that you have an
accurate sample it also reminds you to
pay attention to your pipette technique
to ensure that you're always measuring
out the right amount of samples the
second one would be ergonomic tips
ergonomic takes basically means that it
requires less insertion and ejection
force when you're manually pipetting see
what this means for you is that this can
help reduce the strain on your wrists
and help prevent repetitive stress
injury in other words a tip that is
designed specifically for your pipette
is considered an ergonomic tip another
variation is the specialty tips
specialty tips are specialized for
specific purposes the reason why you
would get them is to either save time
reduce contamination or improve accuracy
for a specific method and you may need
to have a specific pipettor for your
specialized tip
then there are the wide orifice tips
wide orifice the benefit of the white
orifice tips is that they're usually
larger to help
provide then there's the white orifice
tips
we're almost done the benefit of the
white orifice tips is that they're
usually larger to help provide the
flexibility for handling pipette samples
that are difficult it's perfect for you
if you're working on things like you
know macromolecules with genomic dna
transferring fragile cellular samples or
any viscous material there are also gel
loading tips gel loading tips just mean
that you're putting acrylamide or
agarose gels inside a standard pipette
tip which can take a long time so you
want to get a specialized loading tips
to help speed up the process and then
there are solvent-saved carbon tips
these tips are best for handling
combinatorial chemistry to help keep
strong acids bases and organic solvents
from causing pipette failures and
finally there are the single wrapped
pipette tips and as its name suggests
each pipette tip is individually wrapped
with special care
love
attention and the main reason why you
want to get these is for extremely
sensitive applications requiring strict
conditions to be sterile that wraps it
up choosing your pipette tips
is important
wraps it up so you can get accurate
results without contaminating your
pipettes or purchase samples and you
also want to consider before you
purchase your pipette tips to ask for
samples to make sure they work with your
machines and pipettes if you want more
videos like this be sure to like and
smash that subscribe button or if you
have any questions just leave them in
the comments below and we'll get back to
you are we well
you have anything else to say nick yes
and if you're looking for pipette tips
like the ones mr nobel described check
the link in the description
for
the lowest price for the fastest
delivery you can pick two and only two
low price fast delivery link in
description
thank you
i nick miss with the toilet paper next
time
[Music]